my guest this week is an author a
filmmaker a former policy advisor to
Ronald Reagan and a guy who really
really doesn't like Hillary Clinton
dinesh d'souza welcome to the Rubin
report good to be on how is that for an
intro for you would you would you want
that doesn't really like Hillary first
should I have done that very well I
think had we done this a year ago you'd
have to have Obama but we now can cross
out Obama put in Hillary it's you're
pretty much on target right there I'm on
target all right well I'm looking
forward to talking to you because I
think we're going to agree on some stuff
disagree on some stuff and that's what
it's all about and a couple weeks ago
you debated my former boss at the Young
Turks janky augur and we're going to
talk about that more in a little bonus
segment we'll do after but I thought at
the beginning of your debate with him
you laid out a really nice case about
your life and what it was like to come
to America as a young immigrant and and
what America is all about so I thought
maybe you could just sort of recap that
just to start about your story I think I
said that you know I think my stories is
similar to that of millions of
immigrants who have come to America
historically the Irish the Italians the
Jews today the Koreans the West Indian
so most of us grew up in societies that
were messed up India had a legacy of
socialism for 40 years there's very
little opportunity for a young man
trying to make it in the world and also
a lot of corruption a lot of bribery
built into everyday life she can't get a
ration card or you can't get a promotion
you got to slip a slip some bucks behind
them into someone's pocket
so it leaves you kind of feeling dirty
at the end of the day so I thought look
I want to come to a country where
there's a lot of in a sense a ladder of
opportunity and and where a guy who has
enterprise and smart willing to work
hard can move up that ladder and go as
far as his talents will allow and to me
America represents that and that's the
American Dream and my politics to this
very day is based on that so my politics
is not based upon tax cuts a building a
wall it's based upon at the end of the
day which side which party
that ladder of opportunity yeah so
before we get into the party part of it
do you think that that concept itself
has changed over the years so you came
here what year was that I came well I
came as an exchange student in 78 I went
to Dartmouth for four years well ended
up in the Reagan White House in the 80s
yeah was in think tanks for about 20
years
AEI in Washington the Hoover Institution
of Stanford and now I do books and
movies yeah so when you came here and
said would you say that that time or
even through the 80s or even through the
90s would you say that that period of
time allowed for a better opportunity
than it would now that seems to be the
sort of meme out there that the
opportunity now is not as great and I
always wonder if that's actually true
well I don't think it is I think that it
is true to a degree in the sense that
there is more opportunity in certain
fields and less than others so what
happens is you know I think it was the
Economist Schumpeter who said capitalism
is this Gale of creative destruction it
comes and knocks out industries and
replaces them with new ones so a hundred
years ago most Americans worked on farms
and then 30 years later that we only
needed a small number of people with
tractors to be able to farm for the
whole country and all the other guys had
to get off the farm so if you a farmer
not good because opportunity was down
right but obviously new opportunities
were opening up in manufacturing
etcetera so today there are new
opportunities in creative
entrepreneurial fields not just
technology but even services but there's
less opportunity in traditional fields
and so people who go in those fields or
who were trained all their lives fill
stock yeah and people still want to come
here right that that's what I always say
when I hear from my friends on the left
and I was telling you before we started
I'm sort of a recovering progressive I
would say I'm a classic liberal who's
sort of libertarian I'm sort of in that
view right now but I always find that my
friends I left are constantly basically
crapping on everything America is about
and for all our flaws and we can discuss
many of them everyone still wants to
come here right I mean people are not
disappearing from America right people
still want to do better here well I you
know I call this the multicultural
fallacy which is that all cultures are
equal and that no culture is better or
worse than any other well
frankly if that was the case no one
would ever emigrate to some other place
because it's really hard to leave your
family and all the stuff you know in
your life and your school and your
friends you have to uproot yourself and
go into a completely new culture where
you're a total stranger that's not easy
to do and you wouldn't do it if you
didn't think that this new society was
in um in a market way better right now
the one you thing to go I'm gonna leave
everybody I know and everything my
culture everything just so I can go to
somewhere worse right general right oh
it is exactly yeah so you're right we're
still the magnet for the world and that
tells you something yeah I'm curious
because so you're from India your skin
tone is brownish to me is that fair to
say totally okay I did yeah there was
nothing racist or bigoted about it every
time it you every time you say something
obvious to people they you're suddenly
you're big and racist it's gross and
whatever but the Indian community which
is done incredibly well in the United
States doesn't get sort of the social
justice cred despite the color of your
skin which is an interesting little
dichotic well the Indian is sort of seen
as a you know as honorary White's and
this is uh this is what happens to
successful communities it's you know the
left in order to protect its narrative
of oppression has to sort of redefine
successful people as belonging to the
master class because otherwise it would
totally disrupt this idea that you have
to be white and preferably male in
America to succeed yeah so what happens
is these immigrants come to men most of
them today are non-white right most
immanence don't come from Europe they
come from the West Indies they come from
Pakistan and most of these immigrants do
quite well so it's actually the shame of
America that the minorities who have
been here the longest Black's Native
Americans are actually being left behind
with these other groups that kind of
they come to the inner city and they
kind of leapfrog their way out it's
sometimes it takes two generations but
very often their kids at least get out
of there yeah and I know that all of you
would you would lay blame for a lot of
what's happened to the black community
on the Democrats and that's a lot about
what this book and your movie is about
so we'll get to that in a little bit but
first you mentioned that you were you
were a policy adviser for Ronald Reagan
and I always think it's interesting
because Ronald Reagan now is thought of
you know the gold standard for
conservatism and and the right and all
that stuff and I think the right has
really I don't even know that the right
knows what it is anymore because it's
nominees I think really more of a
centrist almost Democrat who's sort of
lying his way to trick people into
thinking that he's gonna believe in
Republican principles but and we can
unpack that if you want but tell me what
was it like working working with Reagan
and in that way was it as magical as
everyone would make it seem well you
know the thing about Reagan was on the
face of it he was ridiculous I mean here
was a guy I'm sort of put in a short day
at the office was always joking around
was difficult to take him seriously and
most of the conservatives at that time
didn't I mean they they look down on
Reagan and they also tended to feel that
Reagan was sort of this bumbling guy and
that you needed all the you need to be
food fortified with all these
conservative think tank people otherwise
he would go off the reservation and but
to me as a student at Dartmouth
listening to Reagan I realized that this
implausible man was actually challenging
some really big ideas and he was
actually offering the the notion that
soviet communism would collapse of its
own weight he was offering this idea
that the whole a mutually assured
destruction system of nuclear policy was
obsolete after 40 years he was
challenging collectivism which was the
big idea of the 20th century and so I
thought wow this guy is actually about
ideas even though he's not an
intellectual and he also just measured
by his own standard accomplished a lot
he said XY and Z 8 years later XY and Z
were happening so I think he'll be
judged as someone who was quite
successful in achieving his goals yeah
whether or not you agree with the goals
sure would you agree with my general
assessment that I lay it out of the
Republican Party at the moment it just
seems to me that it doesn't know what it
is at this point as we're taping this
you know where a couple days or a week
away from the the convention we'll see
what happens I have a feeling he's going
with Newt is VP and that's a little more
of a standard you know someone on the
right and an establishment guy but that
they've chosen for whatever reason and
I understand some of the reasons related
to free speech of just frustration with
the establishment etc etc they've chosen
someone who really in no ways is
conservative really yeah you know the
sir Reagan conservatism was based upon
three very simple ideas the world is a
dangerous place and we need to be a
little bit tough you can't talk you know
a kid can solve every problem with a UN
cocktail conversation right so you jump
would agree with that
some would agree with that number two
that the free market economy is the way
to deliver mass prosperity not to say
that there's no role for government but
the market itself technological
capitalism is the best friend of the
poor and the ordinary guy I think Trump
would also agree with that in principle
and the third one is essentially that we
want to have a patriotic and decent
Society
you know sometimes when we talk in
libertarian terms of the free society we
act as if the content of that freedom
doesn't matter as if the founders would
had no preference as to whether you
became a farmer or say a pornographer as
long as you were free to choose it was
okay with them no they actually had some
idea of what that American dream would
look like and I think Trump would agree
with that too now this all being said
we're in a very different time than
Reagan even most of the ideas of Reagan
preceded Reagan many people are waiting
for Reagan where's Reagan we want
reaganism reaganism was developed before
Reagan Jack Kemp Jean Kirkpatrick many
others were talking about the ideas that
later came to be known as Reaganism
Trump is also running kind of explicitly
as a nationalist in addition to being a
patriot and that is a little bit of a
problematic cord on the right
nationalism yeah and I think that's
what's causes some of the
neoconservatives and those kind of guys
to balk at Trump and then of course
Trump is just such a an unknown a
wild-card and so even for me I'm
uncomfortable because I'm thinking I'm
choosing between a known figure Hillary
yeah and an unknown figure Trump uh and
that's it's difficult to compare yeah
and I know that you don't like the
knowns about Hillary and that's what
this is all about so we'll get to that a
little bit the way we got we gotta go a
little further in term because I'm with
you so you do you consider yourself a
neoconservative i I saw that at some you
know
in Wikipedia I take that for gospel you
know I mean I've been called you know
look the write has been traditionally
divided into the paleo conservatives
were kind of a traditional old line
conservatives then they're the neo cons
who are basically the Liberals who moved
right um predominantly but not
exclusively Jewish and the third is I
would say the evangelical slash
Christian conservatives I actually I
don't have three feet but I kind of have
one foot in each camp
yeah the think tanks I was part of were
neocon for sure um but I was also in my
youth kind of an admirer of Bill Buckley
and that kind of paleo con conservatism
I'm friendly to them to the evangelicals
and have debated atheists and sort of
the president abated some people that
I've got their books right here with
lutely absolutely and uh uh but I'm not
you know I'm not a hard-line
fundamentalist I I keep very good
friendships and relationships with the
atheists like Michael Shermer sure in
fact we're heading off to a libertarian
conference to do a debate on the Bible
oh very nice very soon yes oh we were
debating in a couple of days yeah and
that's what libertarianism of course
should be about that the two of you
should be able to sit down and say well
I'm a believer I'm not a believer but
what's the role of government and all
that stuff and that's yeah that's really
what the the heart of libertarianism is
totally I mean I've always I've always
admired guys like Christopher Hitchens
Shermer guys on the Left I mean I did
civil rights debates with people like
Jesse Jackson many of the civil rights
scholars and they fall into two camps
one camp other guys who enjoy a debate
and recognize that there has an inherent
value in a free society and but there is
another group that if you don't agree
they treat you like the enemy so like
like Chiang Kai you know yeah I kind of
felt like you know this is the guy who
thought it was very upset and then
regarded to use debating the enemy as
opposed to debating a fellow kind of
seeker of truth yeah we're just trying
to test our ideas against each other
figure out who's right yeah well I
almost felt again I wanna do a little
bonus about so don't go too deep into it
but but real quick I felt like you gave
this really nice uh intro on why you
love America and then he basically said
yeah basically I don't want exactly
quote him because I know some people do
it but it basically yeah but now
Republicans
on slavery and it was like yeah like
you're just trying to win points not
make a point which I think you're two
very different things
right no I I think that that's right I
mean I felt I've there are different
types of debates that was a debate where
you sort of came guns blazing and and
and he just kept firing from the first
moment and you know and and I Ike was
trying to adopt a sort of alley
rope-a-dope strategy because I was just
kind of leaning back and let him punch
it not really trying to hit back because
it's silly for me to to you know to
attack his past and so on I really just
wanted to let him go and and ultimately
kind of try to get to the key question
of which historically has been the party
of bigotry and racism which is the party
of racism now yeah all right so I want
to do a little more on neo-cons then
we're gonna get right to that so it
seems to me that the phrase neocon and I
think this is really what you're saying
in a way doesn't really have that much
meaning anymore so it was sort of
classic liberals that found that felt
that as you said the that there was an
inherent value to our culture and that
at some point they felt we could export
this right and then that was sort of
been adopted by the right I guess sort
of like by like a Cheney Bush situation
and we tried to nation-build and it
failed miserably would you agree that
that they were basic failures yeah see I
think when they practice yes I think
that the the Reagan approach was that
you have a principle or an ideal but
prudence is the way that you get from
here to there so for example ideal was
to bring the Soviet Union down but when
the Soviet Union invaded Afghanistan
with a hundred thousand troops Reagan
did not send a hundred thousand troops
to push him out
Reagan basically told the Afghans you
fight will help so you go on the
frontline you defend freedom it's after
all your freedom but we'll give you some
Stinger rockets to shoot down Soviet
helicopters this is called using
prudence as a means to get to your end
now contrast is with george w bush you
know this whole nonsense about the fact
that in order to change a country you
have to invade the place right Colin
Powell's idiotic dictum that if you've
invaded
you somehow own it and you now have a
responsibility to rebuild the whole
place right nonsense you you know
politics is driven by the lesser evil if
you get a bad guy in the out in power
your only responsibility is to put a
less bad guy in his place ideally a less
bad guy who's friendly to you so you can
actually do some business and trade with
him so I think American foreign policy
needs to return to its modest goals of
trade with us and don't bomb us and
that's pretty much it is that the irony
about Iraq that kind of gets lost and
everything is that Saddam was a bad
person we know this we know he gassed
the Kurds and had torture chambers and
did all these horrific things although
the Trump said a few days ago that he
was it last week you know he's he knew
how to deal with terrorists but did a
lot of bad he funded a lot of terrorism
too and all kinds of other stuff but the
irony of Iraq is that we end up getting
rid of a guy that had nothing to do with
9/11 then we finally get the country to
a place where they were having
democratic elections and then Obama
withdrew troops although Bush was the
one that that signed that order and then
the country went to [ __ ] and it's like
we shouldn't I would argue we shouldn't
be there forever but at the same time it
was incumbent upon us not to just pick
up and leave one day where now it's
almost as it's almost as bad right this
very moment as it's bad it been at any
time in the last ten years it just makes
America seem like a terrible ally to
rely on yeah and this is I think why
Karzai turned against us in Afghanistan
yes I I agree we were trying to do
something kind of brave in Iraq which is
to build a Muslim democracy now that's
kind of a good thing to pull off if you
can because there's so little example of
that in the Middle East there are Muslim
democracies elsewhere Indonesia there's
democracy in India which has a lot of
Muslims but there's really no democracy
in the Middle East
that's a Muslim Tomaso we're trying to
make one yeah and it was worth a try and
I could possibly have worked but what we
made it impossible for it to work
because we lost faith in it and we
basically decided to pack up and go home
yeah so it's it's really part of it's a
bigger issue about our elections and
everything because it's like it was
getting better but Obama had committed
to leaving as part of running the first
time so he was
leave no matter what so I would put
equal blame on both of them in a way I
know that Obama didn't start it but by
leaving the way we did here we are yeah
and I think that in all these things
there would you know let's just look
back at Bush if Bush had said look
frankly we don't really know who did
9/11 exactly we also know that it isn't
just Afghanistan because clearly these
characters came out of Egypt and patan
of Pakistan and the some of them came
from Saudi Arabia gets out here at what
17 to 21 right there's there's from all
over the place right now entities so
we're going to adopt kind of wild-west
justice here which is which is the the
sheriff who goes in the bar the bad guys
are in there but he doesn't really know
who they are so you can't just a couple
of bad characters bangs their heads
together and walks out of the bar and
the message to everyone in the bar is
don't mess with us
throws we are rough guys and we shoot
first now if if Bush had said that of
the American people most people would go
go for it
we don't care of Saddam Hussein did 9/11
just go over there and grab some bad
guys and bang their head in the ground
yeah but Bush should do that he came up
with this big elaborate you know
Buffon's mass destruction so this is
sort of like the cops who say you know
this there's drugs in your house I'm
gonna break down your door well if you
want to break down my door you better
find some drugs yeah you don't find
drugs it's gonna look pretty bad yeah
and that's what happened with us in Iraq
the moment that we couldn't find those
WMDs the whole operation I think lost
credibility yeah so all that said would
right now the Middle East it's hard to
tell if it's in the worst meltdown it's
ever been or now it sounds like Egypt's
a little more stable and they're one of
our allies and Jordan seems a little
more salable but Syria certainly I mean
the whole place what would you as
someone that sort of has the the
philosophical underpinnings of a neocon
but I hear what you're saying you're not
for invading places to to give them
democracy what can you then do that
would be more in the Reagan line of
thinking to fix some of this stuff like
Syria for example well I think that you
you want to the simple principle is help
your friends and and curtail your
adversaries and um the reason to me the
Iran deal is problematic is at the end
of the day is Iran gonna be weaker
stronger probably stronger so not a good
idea yeah a serious complicated because
you got it's kind of a replica of the
old Iraq you've kind of got a vicious
dictator in there but he is a secular
dictator
and you've got some bad guys in the
opposition typically the problem has
been that if the bad if the opposition
wins which of that group is going to
take over is it going to be the little
al Qaeda Isis group what happened in
Afghanistan we kick the Soviets out very
good result but then the Taliban the
most ruthless and fanatical of the
opponents they come in and take power so
we were we we helped the Afghans kick
the Soviets out but we did no management
after that right we just let a group
come in that was as hostile to us as the
Soviets would have been so basically we
take a failing store we like put some
paint on it for a little bit but then we
kind of just cut and run when when
trouble starts that that seems to be a
bit of a theme here it's a theme now the
world is a dangerous place we can't fix
it all I don't think we should try to
and where you draw that line because I
think that's an interesting place that
look I have a lot of friends on the Left
that'll say you know we should do
absolutely nothing in Syria I would
argue we shouldn't be nation-building
but if there were you know humanitarian
corridors or something like that then
that would be fine but I think my
friends on the left often think they're
taking the moral position by saying we
shouldn't do anything meanwhile how many
what 300,000 people are dead in the last
five years or something to that effect
you know that that never strikes me is
the moral position it strikes me as sort
of you know the ostrich with the head in
the sand position yeah this notion that
sort of moral positions are held
abstracted from the conditions in the
world I think is foolish I mean we were
right to ally with Stalin against Hitler
Stalin was a really bad guy but Hitler
was worse than opposed a bigger threat
at the time today a lot of people are
like I'll never vote for Trump I'm never
Trump and all this stuff and they say
I'm standing on principle but my
reasoning is look American politics is
played in teams here are the two teams
yeah if you don't want Hillary and the
Democrats well frankly you got Trump and
the Republicans there's no alternative
to those choices historically the
abolitionists we admire them they were
against slavery right but the
abolitionists were cranks you know most
of them their political activity
involved things like let's get together
and burn the Constitution you know that
was what they did right it's only when
the abolitions were integrated in the
looking party in the Republican Party
won the 1860 election the Republican
Party fought the Civil War that's how
slavery ended the abolitionist couldn't
have ended on their own that's
interesting because it sounds to me like
you're selling a much broader piece of
the Republican Party than people think
of it as right I mean you've you've just
said you don't mind debating an atheist
then you can both accept that you have
certain I don't know that Michael I
don't think Michaels uh Republican but
uh but what exactly not rebutted eight
he's a libertarian atheist can be a
conservative shouldn't deny doubt for a
minute
yeah so is so it's sort of branding for
you guys and I think the Democrats have
their own branding problem but would you
say it's a branding issue for the
Republicans in general well I would say
that the the Republican Party has
treated its own brand very badly one of
the things that Reagan did do is he
built that Republican brand and it was a
very good brand in fact it was such a
good brand that the Liberals who had
built a liberal brand by the time Reagan
finished they wouldn't call themselves
liberals even Hillary was asked are you
a liberal she goes no no not a liberal I
and and the Liberals have gone and gone
back to the progressive labels from the
early part of the century
so Reagan actually I did four regressive
will you join me on that right yeah well
the audience knows that's that's my
preference yes
well point the point being that that I
think the Republicans with with Iraq
with all the kind of the bush heavy
spending and deficits that he burned the
Republican brand pretty badly yeah that
was not good
Oh